I'm really loving I bring peace and I've
been kindness and warmth I love the
black people the people in my life my
world they do it their toll
we're honoring mr. T why I met this man
many many years ago in a 7-eleven store
and it said give me your money
[Applause]
great to see you man hey hey you doing
here well one of the Great's Johnny Depp
I'm really congratulations I hear your
divorce is official in Italy you're
finally divorced from bathing apparently
ah still no one can argue that he has
made Trump more than just a name he's
made it a brand a brand like massingill
because he's a bloated stinky douche hey
this looks like a long breast like a
long like with the areola gonna stick
that shows up on my timeline that's
enough that's enough don't put a culture
on it I once did another show that was
similar to this show and I say was Lopez
Tonight anyway so it doesn't exist
anymore so who cares and the other guest
was Justin Bieber and I was just sitting
backstage and was me and the Biebs and
the Biebs must have been about 16 super
nice kid he's mom's the same age as me
because she had him at like 16 or
something like that and I'm sitting here
I got 11 year old niece in Australia so
I go look I never do this to anyone but
can I just ring up my niece and if you
could just speak to her for just a
second I'd be the greatest uncle ever
and he said sure anything for a belieber
he said it right
great yes I love that so I got up in
front of him put the phone on
speakerphone I rang my niece a man
astray was like midday there and I said
hello Sammy
it's your favorite Uncle Jim now I know
what a big Justin Bieber fan you are and
she goes I hate him now I like one
direction well he really wants to talk
to you he was super cool about it I
think it happened to him before I'm not
a big fan of Steve Jobs personally what
are you talking about I just I don't
know I just don't understand what the
big deal was with that guy he's like
Edison I don't know he invented all this
stuff everybody did he did he did he sit
down and like I'm gonna invent the
iPhone and just sat there soldering
possibly welding right did he have like
a crew of guys helping him out sure
maybe he did why when he went to those
nerd fest didn't he have like a like a
like a chorus of scientists behind him
who helped him out too he walked out
like he was Tesla into electricity I
know which they keep this kind of like
told people what to invent like he just
kind of came in like I want my whole
music collection in that phone get on it
[Laughter]
yeah made it happen yeah and then they
have the big nerd concert and he goes
out there by himself
no belt you know sneakers on I just
didn't buy it from my heart this is a
long
I look around this room and just the
home of the blacks and let me say free
god bless you black people I love you I
really do here is your laughing gear I'm
sure one of you guys is up in my hotel
room robbing me
what is your favorite Italian food I
well I will tell you spaghetti and
meatballs but I prefer baloney sandwich
and not just to attract the black men
either who are you supposed to be
Peter sleeps in a parker yeah I was
wondering what happened to Courtney Love
yeah fantastic how's business today
business is you know it's been pretty
good my spidey senses tell me you're
gonna make $4 today you were good
friends with mr. Shaquille O'Neal I've
met him any times Shaq as a girl not
very nice guy what what's what's it like
hanging with Shaquille O'Neal Adam
calling shake I called him long knees
little body that's what I call Shaq has
the body of a Dutch woman that's that's
fine that's why that's thing but Shaq
his miss Shaq's relationship is
complicated because all we do is tease
each other you know all his jokes for me
being small minds of him being big but
naturally I win because I'm a comedian
he's not but lately I'm a tearing him up
man I just hate I hate the way Shaq
Falls like that's what that's what kills
me like literally he falls in steps
he's got like a three step fall anybody
so when he's in the game and he's
playing it's the worst thing I've like
have you ever seen is anybody ever see
check ball I'm just see this me show us
you if this doesn't look like it just
tell me look okay literally it's three
sections this is Shay he goes for a
rebound he doesn't get it oh no oh oh
god no
[Applause]
laid the suck in here is the worst thing
ever nobody can help him up because he's
too big so you just gotta wait there for
a while you see Sugar Shane Mosley one
of the greatest boxers of all time he's
losing his championship belt in a
divorce losing yeah it's like you're
trying to break a man what does she want
those things I think they go with their
shoes when you get a divorce
all of a sudden costs like 50 grand a
month to give a kid Froot Loops
[Laughter]
[Applause]
gold-digging [ __ ] and
[Applause]
not being addressed like now the Bob is
a beautiful face like a flower yeah
cauliflower no offense but your face
looks like a cauliflower no there are
times when bob has something on his mind
when he wears a hat
but no thoughts at all just a hat Bob
you have a lot of well-wishers here
tonight and a lot of them would like to
throw you down one well they want to
murder you in a well it's a little harsh
but apparently they want to murder you
in a well it says here on this card and
Bob is not very worldly he thinks the
English Channel is a British TV station
and not a body of water separating
England and France and Bob isn't the
biggest sports fan I don't think I'm
telling any tales out of school I took
him to a I took him to a ball game and
he came toting a double-barreled shotgun
you remember that I said what the H is
that for Bob said I heard the Lions were
playing the Tigers every day yeah we
know each other a long time we do you I
know you as one of the finest and
impressionist you do you great
impression thing besides that I'm
delighted that you have a show because
you're fresh you're funny you're great
and I want you to know something from my
heart I never liked you
you know but why is what is it about
black men in particular that attracted
you well you know because black men like
the big but it's true give them
something to hide behind when the rent
is due also they're always available to
hang out with you between 9:00 and 5:00
every day
it's a win-win for Lisa limping yeah and
but now there must be a lot of
disappointment now that you you're
getting married I mean you've moved on
and yes I have there's crying all over
I didn't think Lance told anybody he
didn't do anything to me
the only good for me he raised five
hundred million dollars for cancer
research that's what that lied did that
blocked out the Sun yeah wasn't cancer
yeah it was annoyed and I hate how Oprah
was interviewing him and acting like she
was dumbfounded that this guy would do
this like she's been in show business
for 35 years and she can't like wrap her
head around some guy doing whatever it
takes to get to the next level
didn't she for the first five years have
liked midgets who wanted to bang their
male man's boyfriend and she and she
didn't want to do it she didn't want to
do it but she didn't have the power to
say no so she wrote it out and then when
she could make a good decision she did a
show but she stood on their heads
sitting there
[Applause]
give it a good time Michael what do you
mean I'm having a great time all right
well tell your facelift oh my god
there's kids run look and Zac California
ready what's going on how's business
are you set that your parents Brad and
Angelina are getting divorced
you look pretty lovely today thank you
yeah black oh roots and Kunta Kinte
being able to take a joke is so
important in life exactly it's all about
smiling and laughing especially with an
outfit like that love you good luck with
the lipstick on your teeth you're
awesome yeah I'm a loner man I don't
like people so okay I know I don't
yeah just fit the avenue during
Christmas time you can thoughts that go
through my head I just want to chop that
tree down and watch it land on people
wasn't gonna stick to that
how long was the surgery is it a big
it's only 45 minutes honestly but if
you've tried everything and you go look
I'm 51 years old I want to live longer I
finally found a nice guy like a guy
called the Jimmy big balls I got to do
this you know what I'm saying the
saddest thing when you met him did he
introduce himself that way this is what
you you call him this real story I met
him and I was scheduled to go on Howard
Stern like two weeks later and with
Howard you always have to scare up
something fun to talk to him about I
said oh what's more fun than Jimmy sak
so I said okay what is really what is
more fun to stern and that's what Stern
nicknamed thanks Connie any worse Jimmy
Kimmel is a chubby bastard but he's a
chubby bastard who's overcome the odds
10 years ago you wouldn't see a guy like
this on TV unless he was saying time to
make the donuts
Jimmy Kimmel Live has the worst ratings
ever he's the only guy in history who go
from cable to network and get less
famous no one watches your dopey show
Kimmel a horse crapping on a parade
route has a bigger following than you by
the way I'm available to co-host oh well
thank you this is something you tweeted
last week on July 15th breaking news the
country of Turkey will now be called
pastrami the process of riding that oh
how that makes it to be lap comedy
writing you know sometimes the
inspiration can come from anywhere and
no way that one come from
Katz's Deli on Houston Street here I'm
sitting there having a little late-night
snack and I'm looking at the you know
breaking news on my phone and I see
there's a revolution a coup happening
and Turkey and I'm like hey I got some
political you did anyone consider that
to be insensitive one guy wrote back to
me saying at least they won't go hungry